alex wood on the hill today for the
giants making start number 21 9-3 on the
year with a 4-2-2 era
for alex wood who is uh 30 years of age
he is in his
ninth year at the big league level
got him
nice start for alex wood
john gray coming out
lamont wade jr coming up
so for john he's making his 22nd start
of the year overall looking even his
record at eight and eight he's got a 385
earned run average
shawn anderson a pitcher
sean anderson is that's a great slider
and wade is struck out sean anderson was
with minnesota briefly waved went to
baltimore waved he's now in triple-a
with the padres really good again
and this could be one right here
[Applause]
he got his foot out hopefully he didn't
get spiked
how about the range factor for trev
though going up the middle i think he
had trouble um
getting it out of his glove a little bit
on the flip take us through this well he
did right here he got more of a change
up than he wanted to and then for
brendan brennan's going hurry hurry
hurry get it to me yeah he's out
it does put him in an o2 hole but
this is lined and it's right at la
stella
that's a roughing back and that'll end
the inning
crawford to lead things off
bill miller says
he went around
subaru's super mo will give it
clarification
real close
the bat went
past the line that's what i'm looking at
this is to
third back to second on to first how
pretty was that around the horn double
play
the jock and waltz off the mound
mcmahon has been gold glove-like at
third base all year
that's one of those swings about halfway
into it you're thinking geez do you
think anybody's gonna see this no
it's just a strike
and so is that one
nine up nine down for alex wood
dickerson will lead things off wood will
hit second
you know some pitchers i
have read about this couple times where
an organization will just flip the guy
around
not strike three
on the outside corner so one out to
the the other side because it's not like
you you're taking a 300 hitter and
trying to flip him yeah probably gonna
make it out anyhow and this way his
pitching arm is not exposed for a number
of years have always been near the top
of the food chain in inducing ground
balls
there's a ground ball crone
story crone there's your three he's just
ordered it up
and the third component of that is the
rockies year in and year out have had
really good infield defense
no score
top of the fourth inning glad you joined
us four game series wrapping up today
going to get his third strikeout
is the rockies
will strand a pair giants are coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that's a that's a curveball that's a
curveball right there they set him up
with some sliders in and then he just
gets the
uncle charlie to
strike out brandon belt
she's kind of got the midas touch
everything she gets into she
is very good at
popped up
middle of the diamond
who's it going to be
it's going to be the baby giraffe and
that'll end the inning
yes sally dickerson coming up giants
with 176
home runs this year and they've been
shut out in that department last night
and today
on the ground base hit
mcmahon got a little bit of a late jump
on that ground ball and yostremski who
rarely
hits ground balls to short just hit one
there
stremski leany he goes
a one hopper and i guess that's how you
stay out of the double play
his third steal of the year
nobody out runner at second
two and two the count
and here it is
swing and there's a bloop
shallow center falling it's in there
base hit yeah has got a very late break
and now here he comes he's being waved
home by lotus he slides with it
first run of the game
so the giants have a one-nothing lead
got him on a slider so that's out number
one that's a big one that was a good
pitch and a great location
la stella
one for two
high drive
right field off the top of the bricks
[Music]
just missed a grand slam it's three
nothing
and this one almost elevates over the
wall right at the top of the levi
landing and he'll have to settle with a
two-run double
and that's it for john gray
so bud black comes out for the second
time co2 and a strikeout so kinley comes
in and he strikes out flores and bell
to keep it a three-run game
about half the bullpen
game captain would not like to see
even get up today and play catch
got him
poor strikeout for alex wood good slider
so now there's a runner in scoring
position
the pitch
in there's strike three called
fastball right on the inside corner
shut down inning for alex wood we go to
the last of the sixth
got him
what a nice job to throw that's three
strikeouts in a row six total
hampton and daza aboard
bouncer through the right side so the
rockies are on the board pink single for
diaz as hampson scores
and it's 3-1
30th rbi of the season for diaz the last
guy on the bench sam hilliard
and this ball lined to center field
it'll get down
coming around third is dazza and he'll
score it's a one-run game
back-to-back pinch hits from diaz and
blackman here come the rockies
and that'll do it
so wood could not get out of the seventh
the 2-2
base hit right field
here comes wade they're going to wave in
the run here's the throw home it's
online they got him
lamont wade guns them down and that'll
end the inning
what a throw
unbelievable throw
on the fly an absolute strike
oh and one to slater
down the right field line
this is trouble and off the top of the
wall it's going to knock in brian
slater's on the move and now he's going
to drop anchor
and the giants pick up a run it's 4-2
here's the 1-2 pitch
base hit left field
just a solid shot
right past mcmahon and it's 5-2
down here in the night
[Applause]
rough
ball game
so the giants will end up taking three
of four